dai giochi dolci note lo so
angela c'è anche pochi casi non
[Musica]
[Applauso]
è un cagnolino che invece
è nato come un giochino applicazione per
bambini molto carino e un cagnolino
parlante maggioranza c'è un mistero
dietro questo ben e oggi proveremo la
storia di band che potrebbe anche essere
una storia ha paura tanto perché noi
adoriamo le storie private lo sapete ma
sapete anche dal mio libro proposito ce
l'avete scrivetelo nei commenti
e ora iniziamo subito la storia ok credo
che dobbiamo andare qua non che cosa ei
gol di rivedere eccomi quanto siamo
piccoli
e da dare per entrare qui ecco c'è
scritto ecco qua e così la storia allora
tommy e madre i benvenuti nella mia casa
dice tom tom questa mia madre ciao mamma
di tommy dove band dove il cane
balistico i ragazzi piacere di
conoscervi ciao fatevi un giro intorno e
divertitevi lo abbiamo visto altri soci
credo che dobbiamo iniziare a cercare
degli indizi sul caso non è un po presto
avete lasciato un mi piace provate ad
essere mi piace adesso ma che scade il
tempo ma dove si batta reti 13 12
10 9 8 7 se lei voglio dare suggellerà
durate toscano si siete vestiti io non
ho trovato il cane malefico bank io
andiamo a giocare più che prima che
arrivi la notte
andiamo giardino ben ok ragazzi abbiamo
possiamo giocare a calcio
vibrante ed ata non vogliono ma io non
so giocare a calcio lo aspetta e ma non
c'è nessun portiere ok forma libera e
aspettate un unico archivio
chiamato king ben che sparano parlante
venite qui ragazzi divertiamoci eccolo
ha quindi lui ed eccolo è un nuovo gioco
che tutti ne stanno parlato ben realtà
esiste da un po però vabbè che vale
qualche domanda ciao di qualche domanda
ok
dobbiamo per forza fare qualche domanda
band se il reale e lui risponde sì a una
voce un po strada questo man siamo amici
ben dici tu no
si è arrabbiato e ben quanto fa 9p 10
anno si fa domande che sono sì ok ok per
guidare
mero lutto
bene ti piaccio nuova band puoi fare un
giochetto no è insomma non paese ben il
cattivo si sa
cosa sta succedendo il cellulare disse
sembra una canzone no
brand ha hackerato il tuo telefono il
mio no impossibile sono già un col
telefono gigantesco soltanto
venite in casa ho fatto una cena svitato
diamo subito appoggiare guidata mi dice
che ben uscirà da quel cellulare
ma una pizza gigante
vitale penitente solo sulla pizza
e camicia mi dice che di la band sta
facendo
si sta seguendo con una bella fetta di
pizza con un appezzamento la fissa prima
che arrivi ben eliminarci tu mi
stai facendo buio
sono io che dico pizza
ei buio adesso dice la madre è mangiare
una fetta di pizza diventa buio
all'improvviso è arrivato il momento di
andare a dormire
ok qualcosa mi dice che ben assassino ha
rivelato molto il coltello allora
bisogna salire su retro 28 secondi
dove
non li trovate in
sostanza mi dispiace
aiuto che cosa succede sono i campi
tempo già perché si doveva evitare
ecco ecco le parti o no se queste cose
devo aggiungere di robben a forme fette
un secondo
no
non ci credo
trenta minuti dopo
siete ancora sveglie che cosa ci fa la
madre qua sì siamo tutti svegli
perché ho una mazza disponibile razza io
non ce l'ho e avete visto e visionaria
cosa sta succedendo dov'è
aiuta e band dove ben e poi perché parli
un po paura
stato docente
si sta materializzando anno ci ha
risucchiato no
noi entriamo nel mondo di bene adesso è
ancora peggio o amore chiusi nelle
applicazioni e ben
capito dove siamo allora tu hai una
mazza al ben si ok non hai la mazza per
morto eccolo sta dormendo
siamo dentro al cellulare uomo che
offrirgli adesso possiamo andare in giro
presenta vuoi rumore di ben provati
dargli una mazzata ha risposto band si
sia arrabbiato no ragazzi questo non va
bene vogliamo invitare ragazzi
cerchiamo qualcosa per tornare no
restiamo qui per un po dico io sto
scendendo giù in cantina
ho trovato una chiave ok prendila
come si può sviluppare d'acqua prima
parte si svegli e sia spazio a tutti a
fette serve una chiave ha detto no sì ci
vuole la chiave qua cerchiamo la cavate
chi ho trovato quindi la chiave dell
attico di quella bianca
miracco mattina rita mabel in giro che
due è la mazza io no dove sei
e portare
aiuto e
tommy perché poi fa bene ma ci sono solo
io io sono la chiave non posso fare
niente no no quindi devo farlo io da
sola sono dietro di te e io no sebbene
che mi stai seguendo dove sei tu sei
viggiano 6 minuto aiuto per salvare
l'italia si wow sono sceso giù dove sei
aiuto mi segue dappertutto ferito siete
nei trasporti soprattutto in cantina
insieme a me no no no non è sceso in
cantina perchè pensavo che lui non
potesse entrare cantina mancare chi ha
preso
ma come si fa non gli ho capito
veramente non lo so se c'è qualcosa che
si è fatto mille pezzi veramente sembra
strano che sono resi da sconfiggere
allora io ho trovato la chiave del
lattico quindi ci salirei sul relativo
attico attico come si fa ad andare su
nell'attico allora qui e proviamo una di
queste porte tutto presto prima che non
va bene di qua non c'è nessuna porta che
porti a una morta riporta all'attico che
li proviamo quest'altra qui c'è una
stanza con un'altra porta è un rapimento
questa calda di best aspetta sì forse
non imposto giusto reti di aver è come
si fa a salire non capisco sono rimasto
bloccato ok italia v pro a salire anche
se sono rimasto bloccato
c'è una cantina qua con una ragnatela
c'è una soffitta voleva dire cosa c'era
niente di interessante come faccio ad
uscire da qui no purtroppo non c'era
niente là sopra avremo quest'altra
portare qualche altro indizi di una
mente che cosa c'è qui è tutto buio
accedete una luce
ho trovato una chiave è quella grigia
dell'attico questa ok ho preso anch'io
questa chiave dell'attico baciamo se
troviamo qualcosa ok ragazzi allora
l'altro gioco non so perché ma non
continuava formi un grato pagato e
quindi siamo passati al prossimo gioco
se ben malefico eccolo qua non è ancora
più inquietante il cane di g
pronti via blade
gioco sempre una voce stranissima vabbè
ok allora eccolo è già lì vena ottimo
già nella casa di beni di bisogna
raccogliere le monetine
sono visti seguendo l'istinto guerra a
chi apre
questa costosa non lo so che cosa
quale già film eccolo band che lo
scoltenna
nord come si fanno a prendere le chiavi
ma inquietante ma ho interpretato
devo trovare un lucchetto nero aiuto
allora io sono al piano di sopra
[Musica]
anch'io sono parti hanno visto presso
prendendo se se ne volesse si può
trovare su chi pone
abbia preso o no c'è scritto vitale è
morto
poverino eccolo forse questo lucchetto
ne vai vai vai che quello no questo
grigio marrone
allora l'occhietto nero laccato nero
trovi quello tutto nero allora quello
stesso
questo grigio questo che cosa è questo
che conta alle monete mi sa
[Musica]
che
mi 6 febbraio sì sì sì no no aiuto
aiuto aiuto aiuto io devo andare forse e
sottolineo non lo capisco
brava usata
prendiamo punta quella parte da quella
parte a destra questo ed è tornato da
quella parte del territorio questo viola
la
vita non è che voglia di aiutarsi nelle
stanze dopo
ma perché ruta o
bravissimo greta attenta perché secondo
me lui riesce a entrare anche qui
lì c'era gialle grigia ma ancora niente
ombra dell'occhio atto nero ma sono è
l'unica sopravvissuta
no se non altro mi sono la chiave blu
qua o
figurano per queste viola sa da dove la
porta più mi si è aperta questa porta
chiave emerge
da te opportuno testa ok dobbiamo votare
la mappa io voglio provare il
laboratorio tra come laboratorio allora
vediamo come questo bene una sorta di
gremi che ti insegue questo livello
angela c'è anche tu chi piange
15 c'è anche il gatto parlante
convincere anche il gatto parlante
quello bianco è quello nero una e angela
e io ho preso la chiave rossa vado ad
aprire subito la porta qui ok ho perso
la porta bravo mia doppia fibbia cosa
c'è qui chiave blu dobbiamo scappare da
tre personaggi adesso ci
aiuta richiamo bruce non lo chiama blu
sì sì sì sì ho aperto e adesso soldi si
chiama gialla si cela piene di oliva
ha detto tutta
italia slide nome credo che tutti il
killer che figo
enna lo dico chi sono
no
sono io bene adesso
non ci credo 15 ha trasformato in tutti
inverno
ultimo d'oro essere i cattivissimi
cerchiamo i personaggi che si fa a
tutti che sono
rimasti che è successo e chi ha vinto
bongo che abbiamo vinto noi
ok votiamo il prof come votiamo questa
volta sarebbe questo club style club era
bella andiamo all'aperto allora dài
qualcun altro deve votare hanno votato
due per il laboratorio e uno per la casa
di tom altro poi s'è visto report avete
già preso storie paura del mio
nuovissimo libro in tantissimi l'avete
già presi milioni essendo tantissimo
grazie mille sono felicissimo che vi sto
facendo così tanti center e non avete
preso
mancina e ben ok allora abbiamo che cosa
abbiamo
aiuto allora abbiamo cacciavite non so
che cosa serve il cacciavite che cos'è
questa o con taser vediamo provocarlo
contro ben
fa paura o no
mi ha eliminato ora sono io beh no no
scopo del marito cerchiamo unitario
vitale 6 pronto essere eliminato
no no no no no
no
non ci riesci a prendermi
dov'è finito bene chi ha
già eliminato
siamo di nuovo nel laboratorio eco
angela
[Musica]
allora dài questa volta saliti a ruby
perché sono già tom
non lo so sono il tomo principale aiuto
c'è scritto che dobbiamo andare da
angela eliminiamo vita ha già verificato
subito era giusto pignorati mio alleato
non è vero no non sono più nel gioco
nemmeno è no dovresti essere tom ha
deluso perché presto eliminiamo questo
giocatore
capisci marito se la chiave
ma dove angela oggi la vediamo se qua
angela napoli la chiave
forse qua negli esperimenti
se progettare e io voglio andare a
prendere angela la mia vita
eliminiamo questo giocatore perché sono
usciti tutti quei giochi
hai visto che c'è anche uno e due poi
mettere anche le scarpe non è cambiato
niente prossimo dove sei un angelo
eliminiamo che tanto giocare o se non
riesco a trovare oggi vediamo vediamo
l'ora di freddo non stai andando il
gioco fu la vittima 1 o tempo
fa meno paura visto poi
quando chi prova di te non riesce a
prenderla stiamo rincorrendo
una cosa è uscita la porta e aspetta la
subito da dietro così quando esce
così non riuscirà mai
ciao ciao ti sto aspettando
dovresti andare poco poco sul lato
no l'inchiesta mai presto mancato nomi
adesso
ho vinto no ce n'è un altro che è appena
entrato dove crisi appare bravo
[Musica]
tom akira sorgendo di incontrarsi qua ok
scoprire cosa è successo
devo scoprire cosa va così questo
aiuterà ben o pensa di galloway queste
macchie per favore tomba dovrebbe
esserci una gelosia mica piscina
nessuno mi fermera del dal finire il mio
lavoro
ok ma vivi praticamente tutti questi
personaggi che erano delle applicazioni
parlanti sono diventati tutti i malesi
posso dire una cosa sono io ben
ok allora non mi uccidere per favore
allora vediamo vediamo o ad
ambientazione mi piace un sacco
e cerchiamo le chiavi prepariamo le ali
assassino
ci sono le tende che cosa posso fare con
lui ma adesso non gli altri giocatori
meno male c'è un altro giocatore qua
dove sono le chiavi c'è un altro bene
adesso o no
lì c'è un personaggio ma un immobile
non possiamo andarcene più che non
riusciamo a capire cosa sta succedendo a
aiuto non si bene il mio pensiero e
dosare allora
aiuto che ovvia non trovo nessuna chiave
c'è una via buia aperta come chiave
qualcuno ha aperto il campus ai devo
trovare il lucchetto blu questo e bruno
e viola come fa correre così veloce
aiuto concreto blu
ma dove siete tutti non riesco a
trovarmi mi devo eliminare meglio capi
aiuto ci sono
21 sono io lo sento mi sento di serie a
della vita tu hai visto per l'aiuto che
non ha permesso turbo ha messo il turbo
vediamo che non fosse
o no qua ci vuole la chiave verde
ma dove la porta blu la trova dopo siamo
tre band o no ancora più difficile
barbablù non c'era forse penso di vedere
in italy si e propria vita io no
scappa via no privato mi ha eliminato
mille mila volt
adesso il limite dove sta scappando no
vabbè non c'è nessuna casetta blu non è
possibile
dove t sta nascondendo unità
non posso andare più avanti ha messo
tutto
la casetta blu o forse raviola
[Musica]
a noi questo è un mio amico
ma quanti siete
tantissimi
[Musica]
succedono diventata ben anch'io
non sarà deciso a trovare la casa
ok ora possiamo dominare gli altri sei e
tu quale siamo tutti uguali ai fatti
prendiamo questo giocatore
ebbene l'unico questa bravissima
difficile che si riesca a scappare
sì molto
lasciate un bel mi piace se volete che
proviamo altri giochi torben malefico
eravamo quattro case linee su cui
cliccare per vedere inoltre altri
cliccate su quella che preferite
ciao